well I think being a happy and
comfortable in your skin counts for a
lot having decent relationships with
those who are close around you whether
that be your family a media relations
other relations circle of friends
co-workers feeling that you're doing
something that's sort of adding to the
good side of you know world progress
from time to time and not just leading
some avaricious selfish existence the
ability to travel the ability to you
know I wouldn't say it live out your
dreams but to basically to be able to
achieve goals that you set for yourself
and have them attainable you know brings
one great satisfaction a good balance
between you know your personal life and
your so-called work life being able to
for me to feel that you know you have an
ability to you know be creative in
whatever form that takes you know put
things together in new ways or create
new things all together
you